I'm here to honor the sacredness of life
that I see at the border in South Texas
in 2014
I visited a detention facility for
hundreds of little children immigrant
children were detained for several weeks
in conditions that were very
heartbreaking they were dirty and muddy
and crying their faces were full of
tears I had the opportunity to go in and
be with them and they were all around me
they were little ones not some of them
not older than five years old and they
were saying to me sakha me Dickie get me
out of here for for what I used on me
please help me it was so difficult to be
there with them I started to cry with
them in and I told him let us pray
mama sorry sorry and they repeat it
after me
Josie though I use a nose God please
help us as we prayed I could see their
Border Patrol officers looking through a
glass window they were at the verge of
tears as they heard the children praying
and witness I had a little boy get close
to me closer because they were all all
over them we can barely fit in that
little cell
this little boy tells me I heard on me
here though you may call me mama please
help me I want to be with my mother she
is here I I was separated from her
I said to him mijo if your mom is here
I'm certain you will be reunited when I
walked out of the cell an officer got
close to me and said to me sister thank
you you have helped us realize that
they're human beings
you know sometimes no matter what job we
have we must never forget to recognize
the humanity in others otherwise we will
lose our own humanity let me tell you a
bit about what I see and what I do in
the southern border of the United States
where I live and where I work hundreds
of families enter the United States by
crossing the Rio Grande River and once
they're in the United States many of
them are given permission to continue
their process of immigration at another
point in the United States what has
amazed me for this all these years has
been the amazing humanitarian response
of the community there in South Texas
thousands of volunteers have given over
time so generously for me they're all
amazing people and the whole community
city government from local business
leaders to civic organizations of faith
communities in the border patrol and ice
we have all come together in an effort
to help a hundred and fifty thousand or
more immigrants since that first day
that we got started back in those first
days when we were first involved in
helping the immigrants we were at our
respite center and an officer from the
city walks in and tells me sister what
are you doing here I turned and looked
to see what was happening at the respite
center
I was amazed at what I was seeing there
were hundreds of volunteers helping so
many families there that needed help
given them ways to get cleaned up and to
get clean clothing food hygiene items
just loving compassion was seen
everywhere so I turned back and then and
I responded to him and I said restoring
human dignity that's what we're doing I
don't think he expected that answer from
me because he took a step back and then
approached me again and said sister if
we if I had a magic wand what would that
magic wand do for you
showers sure you know that evening we
had a mobile unit of eight showers
amazing and after that we had a hundred
percent support of the city government
we were there wanting to make sure that
we were helping and be successful with
our response to the so many families
that we were seeing every single day I
think that we must help others see what
we see I think it's important that we
can share that with others you probably
heard this idea before that we must
always see God's children as equally but
in order to do that I think it's
important to be able to to see them as
people to be able to have a personal
encounter when we can feel what they
feel when we can understand what they're
hurting to really meet up with them it
is then that we are present to them and
we can make their humanity a part of our
own humanity and we recognize that there
we are all part of the same human family
during those days I had a lady
approached me and tell me sister I am a
hundred
percent against what you do helping
these illegal aliens and I said to her
let me tell you what I do and why so I
share with her and introduce her the
families and the children share the
stories that they are leaving when I
finish talking with her she turns and
looks at me and says sister I am a
hundred percent in favor of what you're
doing you know that evening her husband
calls me he tells me sister I don't know
what you did to my wife but this evening
she came home and she said if sister
Norma ever calls you you make sure you
do what she tells you so I'm just
reporting to let you know I'm here to
help in any way well you know I I'm
thinking that I say the personal
encounter that she had I think it's a
nice idea a nice message but I I don't
think it's the whole story not encounter
we must put aside our prejudice that we
have to work others that separate us and
there are not allow us to see them our
walls that we put up in our own heart
they keep us separated from others when
we're able to do that we're able to
reach out to them you know it I think
what doesn't make it possible is fear
that we are afraid and because we're
afraid more than likely it's because we
have seen in the media all this negative
rhetoric that we hear about immigrants
there are demonized like they're like
human that we can discard them and we
can get rid of them and not even feel
bad that we're doing that immigrant
families are not criminals immigrant
families or like our families like our
neighbors they're good people who are
entering our country and coming to the
United States only simply because
they're fleeing away from violence and
they
to be safe unfortunately what we see at
the border is terrible
people are hurting and suffering
thousands of them are and mostly because
I feel it's because of those walls that
we put up that we have in our hearts
that makes us not care so we have
policies that are returning people back
to Mexico so they can wait and they wait
there for months in conditions that are
horrible where people are suffering and
hurting abuses and with not even the
meat that means to be ok I think that it
is true that we must keep our country
safe that we must make sure who enters
our country the criminals should be put
away but it is also true that we must
not lose our humanity in doing this that
we must have policies and procedures
that do not contribute to the human
suffering that people are already
suffering and then we can find solutions
that are respectful to all human life we
can do this if we can allow the best in
us to come out because what I see at the
border our families men who will take a
child and will come try to comfort that
shell that is crying because that child
is crying for her their own dad and this
men are are crying with that child
I see many women who drop to their knees
praying as they pray in task even as his
children who have been separated from
their parents for months and when
they're reunited they're afraid to
separate themselves from them because
they're afraid they will lose their
family their mom again once a child
looked up to me as after she was
reunited and she said to me oh no boy
you are
today I'm not going to cry and I said
for Kimmy huh it's because I have been
crying for the past whole months because
I didn't know where my mother was
but Tenaya I'm going to be with her the
day I visited the detention facility
back in 2014 there was a little boy who
who approached me and asked me where for
me to help him find his mom
well that evening when I was at the
humanitarian respite Center the little
boy walked in with his mother and as
soon as he spotted me he runs to with me
I go down to greet him and he just
throws himself to hug me it was so
beautiful it that was truly a beautiful
human encounter I think it's the
humanity at its best it is what we all
are called to do think about it we just
need to allow ourselves to get close
enough to see and we will care thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]